hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich bin dumm und das regt mich
jeden Tag auf doch heute habe ich die
Möglichkeit das zu ändern und allen das
Gegenteil zu beweisen denn wir machen
dich
remastered IQ-Test dieser Test ermittelt
anhand eurer grafischen
Kombinationsmöglichkeit mit dem
logischen Denken euren IQ und das im
spielerischen Sinne Hood your drawing
into the beaker you can not draw in the
blue area das hier ist unser
Spielbereich und unsere Aufgabe in
diesem ersten Test ist es nun etwas zu
zeichnen was hier in diesem Behälter
reinfällt allerdings nur im schwarzen
Bereich
das hat nicht geklappt
[Musik]
130er IQ das ist make the red ball
touch the red area wenn das ein roter
Ball ist sondern auch nicht dieser Ball
muss also hier lang und dann irgendwie
hier rüber und hier in den roten Bereich
rein das heißt wir brauchen hier erstmal
eine Rampe die wir irgendwie so hier
hinstellen zack das hält auf jeden Fall
und jetzt irgendetwas was den Ball hier
runter oh Gott
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir können jetzt auch hier auf IQ drauf
klicken und uns unseren bisherigen IQ
anzeigen und errechnen lassen aber nicht
mit uns wir machen erstmal noch ein
bisschen was something and touch the red
area ich könnte quasi so eine Wippe
bauen
dann hier ein Ball drauf und hier ein
größeren Ball so dass der den kleinen
Ball hochkickt
was ist denn das für ein scam das der
kleine den großen rüber geht das sieht
aus wie eine Strich Figur hier gerade
zwei Augen nein wir müssen das Malen was
diesen Bereich hier berührt also
logischerweise hier oben rüber fällt
kann ich dich hier sowas kleines mal nee
das halt immer da lang hä ah ich baue
hier eine Rampe die hier vorne steht so
und dann hier ein Ball der hier
runterfällt
ich bin gerade 130er IQ make the red
Square touch the left wall
wir müssen also diesen roten Block das
ist auch immer noch kein Rot ne sorry
aber die wollen mich eigentlich
verarschen der Block muss auf jeden Fall
die linke Wand berühren das heißt wir
müssen hier irgendwie ein Gewicht
erzeugen was das ganze Ding rüber kickt
kann ich nicht hier irgendwie so ein
Ding zeichnen was dann runter fällt und
das Ding schiebt
nein ich gehe jetzt mal von hier ein
bisschen weiter hoch nämlich hier hin
der drückt es aber nicht runter die
Sache ist allerdings wenn ich jetzt hier
ein Ball drauf lege kriegt der nee der
fährt einfach nur rüber
okay wie wird das Funktionieren ich
könnte hier so ein Druckmechanismus
bauen und dann hier rüber dass das sich
vielleicht irgendwie so nee das bleibt
stehen
das Ding ist halt dass ich so wenig wie
möglich zeichnen darf je mehr ich
zeichne das so schlechter ist mein
Rating und mein IQ am Ende ich könnte
jetzt natürlich ganz easy so vorgehen
dass ich irgendwie erst so ein Ding
mache und dann mache ich noch ein
zweites
und dann mache ich beispielsweise auch
noch ein drittes und dann müsste ich
auch gleich schon direkt an der Wand
sein wenn ich jetzt nämlich das vierte
gezeichnet habe zack so
ich schalte das jetzt ansonsten
fitzelpenis hier oder was selbst wenn
ich so macht klappt
60er IQ habt ihr gesehen dass das klappt
nicht wir müssen uns also am nächsten
jetzt richtig am Riemen reißen make the
ball touch the red area was
[Musik]
hier ist die Area der Ball soll
also das ist ja relativ easy oder
das war's
make the red Bold Touch the red area ich
probiere es erstmal mit einer
klassischen Brücke und zwar erstmal den
Grundpfeilern hier und dann einer Brücke
die wir hier drauflegen
ihr seht schon das ist beides auf einer
Höhe ca ich probiere jetzt mal den Ball
hier rüber zu kicken dann so
oder wir bauen eine leicht abgeneigte
Halterung in etwa so
setzen da drauf unsere Brücke so dass
der Ball hier runter rollt
und sobald der Ball hier vorne ist
lassen wir
schafft aber das hier rüber zu hüpfen
wenn ich den ganz doll anschubsen mit
ganz viel Gewicht
das hier ist unsere Brückenkonstruktion
wir lassen den Ball runterfallen und
malen jetzt einen riesig fettes Ding was
den Ball
hochschleudereinigung
wie soll denn das gehen
ich kann dir nicht hier zeichnen ich
kann ja nur hier zeichnen das fällt dir
alles runter
nicht verzagen Flughafen wir machen das
gleiche Prinzip wie vorhin bauen nämlich
eine Waage hier vorne ein Behälter und
hier vorne
einen kleinen Ball der Ball kommt hier
rein und den schleudern wir hoch indem
wir hier eine riesen Gewicht reinfallen
lassen
[Musik]
in die Container es ist auf Zeit das ist
auch Zeit ich lass einfach
und dann oh das passt wir haben es
[Musik]
ich habe das Licht erfunden lower the
code hänge wir zeichnen hier etwas hoch
was wir dann hier runter hängen lassen
mit einem riesigen Gewicht hier
und dann nur einem ganz leichten Gewicht
hier
alles ist korrekt außer das Gewicht muss
ich direkt hier links befinden wenn das
jetzt nicht klappt dann ist das die
falsche Taktik
[Musik]
Millimeter
Halterung und hier das Gewicht
vielleicht geht's ja auch so eine
bessere
warum macht er denn jetzt ein Excel
Update eigentlich wollte ich weniger
malen aber es geht ja anscheinend nicht
anders bei diesem militärshaken
wir habens
wir haben es
danke letzter Test für heute the yellow
ball with Start moving when something
touch is it but the balls put the pot
die gelben Bälle fangen also an sich zu
bewegen sobald etwas sie bewegt dann
werden sie pink oder wie die halt sagen
würden rot und fallen runter also fallen
der Gravitation
es ist also eigentlich relativ simpel
wir benötigen nur eine Schanze hier die
sich so hält und jetzt einfach
Kleinigkeiten die die Dinger berühren so
dass alles da reinfällt
besser hätten können
wir schauen uns mal unseren IQ an
ein IQ von 56 bedeutet dass jemand eine
leichte Intelligenzminderung hat eine
Person mit einem IQ von 56 wird
erhebliche Schwierigkeiten haben
alltägliche Aufgaben zu erfüllen und
wahrscheinlich von anderen abhängig sein
um Ihre Bedürfnisse zu erfüllen sie
werden auch wahrscheinlich erhebliche
Schwierigkeiten haben ihre Umwelt zu
verstehen und zu kommunizieren
angeblich habe ich auch noch eine
geistige Behinderung
ich gehe dann mal besser zum Arz